all right so I'm just gonna just gonna
do it you ready here I go I'm gonna do
it I'm gonna start this show hi
everybody I'm Jonathan Shawn's and today
I have another tactical challenge for
you so wouldn't you see it on your
screen go ahead pause your video and
we'll see if you can solve this one
so today's puzzle comes to us from one
of our own instructors here he's asked
lassic coordinator at the Chess Club
Kyle Weber who had the white pieces in
this position and he's been as high
rated as about 2,000 USCF so in this
position he missed the tactic
unfortunately a really nice move go
ahead pause your video see if you can
find it okay so in this position with
the King on e6 just right in the middle
of the board looking for some sort of
discovery that my twin is very tempting
however unfortunately none of the
discoveries are actually sufficient for
a major advantage for white in the game
Kyle played Knight to c6 a nice check
and he does indeed pick up the exchange
however for the exchange black has three
pawns his King is a little bit iffy if
we just follow the game a little bit
more you should probably take with this
pawn because after this trade I mean the
black King is no longer in danger black
is still has three pawns for the
exchange so it's not at all clear that
that white is even better in this
position we return so going back to this
position if you thought it was some
knight discovery go ahead and pause and
think again another very tempting move
when we consider where the black Queen
is it looks like well maybe the Queen
doesn't have a whole lot of squares and
that is indeed the key to understanding
this puzzle so one very tempting move is
this tactical looking move c4 and well
this is a pretty good move for white
it's certainly not the best so the point
is I mean there's no good square for the
black Queen
if for example you decide to go to be to
there's at least some discovery against
the king followed by taking up the Queen
okay if instead though black plays the
best move which is just to get a couple
pieces while he can for the Queen
again we get a position where the black
King is still in a little bit of danger
however you do get two pieces for the
Queen you're still up three pawns and
you know white is probably better here
but it's not entirely clear how you
should go about winning this position so
we returned so this is your your last
chance here to find the best move so
again you can pause if you need to here
is the solution in this position you
actually have the amazing move rook to
a5 with a similar idea that there's no
real good place for that Queen to go
in fact the engine will suggest that
your best move is actually just to take
this Knight and then white can just take
back with the bishop so after rook to a5
instead of that the point is of course
if you take now there's discoveries that
will end up picking up the Queen you can
go either to c6 or to c4 and after
either one of those moves after the King
moves you just take the Queen and now
you're up a lot of material and there's
no real alternative to it again b2 is
the only real safe Square for the Queen
but again there's a Czech discovery and
then you pick up the Queen so thank you
everybody for watching I hope you
enjoyed this tactic let me know if you
were able to get it in the comments
below hit like share subscribe and we'll
see you next week for another tactical
challenge